[Music]
high up in the Cordillera mountains in
the philippines in the village of bus :
lives a woman who is the last of her
kind
hooker and national native Anu we shall
look even hotter
[Music]
Mumbai Batak is the name given to the
traditional tattoo artists of the
Kalinga ethnic group the artists are
masters of their thousand-year-old trade
originally giving tattoos to warriors
who won in battle a shadowy
yuki-chan a chicken piccata shyaa'n
learn with Ruth Marie Ragnar Sharon
Sharon hi yukky welcome Raja to new
photo okay boys eternity photo every
year thousands of tourists make the
journey to see Wang on and get one of
her famous tattoos oh hello Michelle - I
know - ooh - Iranian food we shall we
Shannon petit Appy Satan and you is so
to share say dioxin jato you rip out hey
Kevin
your turn yeah be a revolution
[Music]
I don't know haha up but other if no one
could earn a new one my old colleague
Wang odd is now the last Mumbai Batok
but she's teaching her granny's to carry
on the family tradition
yeah I don't know she's your yoga in
green color racism and xenophobia are
unfortunately everywhere
however one woman is turning this into
this meet Germany's hate destroyer
[Music]
in Germany former teacher M elements s
ROM has made her life mission to remove
any neo-nazi stickers and graffiti
around her country there's no easy feat
though nein and how does one arm oneself
for a war against street 8 medium parent
HIV or then a collection fan all the
evening father mel has been covering
removing and obscuring these messages
since the eighties she keeps a record of
everything she's wiped out all over her
country said Vicki Janowitz my trust
until you have esteem you busy man
deputies Allison Prince Ferg Erica
Altima every day except for Sunday's her
Mela packs her bags and heads off to the
streets
sometimes she now's a big one like this
heart it used to be a swastika other
times it's small but even the crudest
message doesn't slip by my new Schwartz
I'd violated Roku preg the sphere found
an artifact and had to Houdini Topanga
that fatso me taboo and achievement in
yet in had septa do a gamma started
Islamic they're shocked - Leland it
would take first to admit difficulty
defeated and as long as as hate in this
world our mela will be there can in hand
and if we stand a decent man is and how
is the comment on the u.s. hurt after
cheaters alert the site each tab
indicates knowledge of freedom
[Music]
another Nova Mary ordered alleged car
body
[Music]
carnival and muginami or do negator
buddy he's gonna karate
[Music]
mera naam Chandra tomorrow Moretti for a
mess up super liver volume a pencil
humor canary
Megan Leggett Oliver Gemara Alton a
Malaga we may build ilma both cushy we
taking per bar / averted aru CT mara
gamma or talk of Varginha personal naked
a Gurkha in the Kerwin opossum Creek
[Music]
subsidy miracle Norwich a lot ahead of
this map nice up Danny be a mime
arbequina awakened cat right oh I'm
gonna tell ascertain by curry cream
maiden the would attract a homeless
already said Jim a metal guitar Jim
where Mary pure water who say mozzarella
Newton Amara they took a lair Chris you
got any money
I'm knockin alegre-wood ashimelda kiauna
they color unlucky when they were what
they called Qataris watercolor good life
became a Bob cook at a minor key vocal
on video
led nowhere give the dunya Corsica to
Hamdani concept
nashwa race has no soup in Korea
[Music]
move the together the aperture is my
achievement but I'm mr. Samuel Ratchett
sir
I think it is noble partner alligator
[Music]
here in the st. petersburg apartment
building you can find tatiana subo tina
better known as the green-screen grandma
a retired engineer tatiana has attracted
a following creating some unique content
for YouTube
Tatiana's channel has almost 30,000
subscribers and over two and a half
million views the previous mature
ecologist illegally let me get the
conditional kalaallisut prism surprising
because Tatiana is completely
self-taught monkey young vigil of
intelligence realistic I think they're
called a zero and a fool nearby the
genie phone most no dolly he studied
Luiza stuff much tinier she soon appears
programmer premier proof got to refute
the place with a montage what it a game
of does immunity be once she graduated
from puppetry that Tiana's channel
really took off there was one video in
particular that really propelled her to
the national stage my mentor with a the
booted Lavinia Kasasa postponed both vjg
meto truly Couture yes Neela mega would
you want an article by caliber
chocolicious fortress motor it will
clear all the cherries me it's just a
beautiful the river gravel Aquinas
panning just a scared person canal water
doubling Neolithic weenie administer
despite a large and growing audience
that Jenna doesn't see herself as a star
yes to assure an attack minions to
youtuber is business Capri didn't appear
a Spanish dominant
Buddhist Kazakh malinka Malik Michelle
knows with a baby star now but you gotta
be famous
don't you a busy mother bigger than you
scroll back at you
[Music]
[Music]
we all crave our grandmother's cooking
right for what if there were a place
that you could go anytime and get that
home-cooked meal from anywhere in the
world
99 challenge' monta that place exists in
Staten Island just behind that
scaffolding right over there
[Music]
meet Joe he's Italian by way of Brooklyn
my name is Jody Scaramella
and I own Enoteca Maria we don't employ
chefs we employ grandmothers when Joe
look in the restaurant in 2006 he
noticed something every culture was
coming to the restaurant to celebrate
these Italian grandmothers so I thought
to myself unless would it be if we
celebrated everybody's culture and so
Nonna's of the world was born they are
probably somewhere between 30 and 40
grandmothers from different countries my
name is Habiba I throw my Danya my name
is Luca Finland from Moscow Russia so it
was Apple there vengo de lima parent
company lanka bulgaria dublin ireland
from our menu window sorry this
argentine each night there are two
grandmother's cooking one is always
italian the other from somewhere else
when they're in the kitchen cooking it's
a completely different energy it's their
day to shine it's their day to show what
their cultural cuisine is all about you
know it sounds kind of corny but they do
cook with love and then feeling for jose
about more than the restaurant when I
opened the Enoteca I was really
grief-stricken my mom and my sister had
asked
it was comforting to have these
grandmother's in the kitchen cooking and
you know they would pinch my cheek and
say you want to try this and at that
point I realized that what we were doing
was much bigger than I thought it was
going to be when you walk through the
restaurant if you listen every table
that you pass by they're talking about
their mothers or they're talking about
their grandmothers it kind of evokes a
trip down memory lane
[Music]